Well we need the SyncThreads call for correctness.
This is what ensures that all the data in the tile has been placed in the shared memory,
before we attempt to copy it to its transposed location in global memory.
So we can't really eliminate the SyncThreads call.
Now the more threads in the block, the more time on average they spend waiting.
So reducing the number of threads that are actually waiting in the barrier
by reducing the number of threads in the block will work,
whereas increasing the number of threads per block will make the problem worse.
And this final one is a little more subtle. And this, again, verges on a ninja level optimization.
Every thread block runs on a single SM but every SM can potentially hold more than one thread block.
In this case, the threads in one thread block can still be making progress while
those at the other thread block are gathering at a SyncThreads barrier.
So this final strategy of increasing the number of blocks per SM can actually be a good one as well.